tampons and pads I think there's really
a whole night like that's I think you
just revealed that you've never found
the clitoris hey I was we going on mithi
what's up I'm Jeff hi I'm Josh I'm Ian
and today we're taking a woman's sex ed
quiz you know I feel confident about it
and you know very generous yeah I think
I'm sir extremely important because I
mean you got to know what you're doing
before you know what you're doing you
know yeah so I went to Catholic school
and that was a little different like
even seeing the nudie mag was a sin and
then public high school
they weren't straightforward like put
the rubber on the banana so I got I got
both sides of it growing up after like
women's sexual education is is important
just like women you need to know every
part about it if you plan on taking part
in it but also yeah I think I'm
knowledgeable you know I had a lot of
women in my life growing up you know I
have a daughter so I feel like I got it
I don't know why I keep doing it but
yeah pretty confident in my ability all
right let's uh get it poppin through
this the word vagina technically refers
to the entirety of the female anatomy
the exterior parts the female anatomy
the canal that connects the uterus to
the labia minora the tube that urine
flows out of well snot definitely not
the arrows out of and I think that's see
off rip seed because yeah yeah the canal
that connects the uterus to the labia
minora definitely definitely go is see
we said the canal that connects the
uterus to the labia minora that was
correct all right off to a good start
let's start boom oh there it is good
work how should the vagina be cleaned
use soap and water inside your vagina
you should use douches regularly the
vagina is self-cleaning and does not
require you to clean it you should rinse
it once a day
does not require you to clean it which
is why women are cleaner than men
the human body's pretty self-reliant
I've always heard that it's a
self-cleaning spot a presence not I were
in self-cleaning organ two for two and
clean their own just sufficient men you
walk around with vinegar smelling right
clothes and stuff don't even be using
wipes before we get into action you know
I do
how long is the average menstrual cycle
five days 14 days 21 days 28 days is
this the whole cycle yeah I feel like
this is they trying to trick us because
yeah because you know most people
believe the period is just the the
menstrual cycle has just appeared where
you're bleeding 21 21 maybe 14 days if
it's like the whole cycle looks like the
actual like the menstrual cycle that's a
whole yeah yes we're gonna go with 28
yeah let's try 28 it's like a month if
it's really if it's 21 like I just now I
just felt like a hope I feel really bad
I'm you're doing all right you you can
pull executive session on 21 I've I
think 14 if you're going a full cycle I
beg differ on this one on the 28 days
whoa BAM let's go
good times oh my god because it doesn't
count others count that's like the whole
like begin cycle so it's basically just
like right honk its and continuously
just basically never ends
yeah is it more hygienic to remove to
remove pubic hair around the vulva true
or false
oh that's false pubic hair is actually
what is there to keep it clean
pubic hair is supposed to
jackets in the genitalia the removing is
just kind of the sexy stuff because of
porn and you know they actually happened
like in the early nineties when we
wanted to shave stuff keep a cute yeah
the cute barely legal sub the removal is
what's destroyed crab lice like they
they're almost extinct now because
because doesn't exist
adult films have came back around on
that my friends tell me I'm really just
watching the Bible Channel
on average how much blood does a
menstruating person lose during a period
one tablespoon six to eight tablespoons
one cup one pint this one hard because
yeah yeah I've guessed this on average
so because I was trying to be like oh
you know you got you heavy a light flow
but it's on average on average I'm going
in the middle of all of them have a hard
like thing like a pint of beer like
that's like I don't want to think that's
all that blood like well I don't either
but I'm just saying like cup is the safe
bet the pint is what my heart is saying
but I'm gonna go with you on the safe
tampons and pads I think there's really
a light that's too much I know I know
do you want to fight no he was a good
cop I want it I actually wanted to be
like optimistic one cup we ended up
going with a pint what wow oh good well
you know we had a cup so that was that
was good like yeah what is the function
of the fallopian tube it transports the
OVA egg from the ovaries to the uterus
allows for proper urinary functions acts
as a natural filter for toxins and the
blood streams
it increases estrogen estrogen during
times of menstruation I'm thinking it
transports the egg from the ovaries to
the uterus
it's the transports the egg from the
ovaries to the uterus yes
yeah all right yeah what were you
thinking I was gonna go with B there's a
louse for proper your urinary functions
like I'm gonna go with you yeah okay I'm
gonna go with that just because I'm
talking about them fallopian tubes a lot
when when I was starting to having a
daughter so I'm not there yet
all right whoa I am look at that we're
getting like the technical stuff and I
remember the diagram yeah
true or false Disney produced a short
film called the story of menstruation in
1946 Oh trying to turn a teach people
especially in 1946 they're like yeah
this is probably before the PC no
internet also I think Disney was whiling
back in the day you know yet Donald Duck
as a Nazi it was crazy 1946 though like
I feel like that's true I wouldn't yeah
that exhaust early days of animation
they're like yeah let's make some sex ed
and I'm sure it's I'm sure it's also
pretty wrong so yeah for sure till now
and then all right we're gonna go true I
just really hope Mickey Mouse is not in
it it's all about me yeah yeah
we went with true Oh is anyone out yeah
what do you think like good yeah we said
true what does PMS stand for pee pee
premenstrual soreness post minstrel
syndrome premenstrual syndrome post
mental syndrome post mortems
it's a premenstrual syndrome definitely
as I say it's definitely before and then
soreness is not really yeah yeah so do
that in unison even solid on that one
they got like because we know that does
when we're in trouble
premenstrual syndrome look at this
another one
Thanks all right that's all right
yeah the shape of the clitoris resembles
the boat a button a rod of being a
wishbone for being bean and some bean
button in a button
we're gonna have a cat can we can we do
a 50/50 on it doesn't mean yeah okay
bean I'm being I'm gonna go with me but
like if it's wrong III I'm why why why
are you saying bean I have a theory of
why you think it's being is there I
don't want to say some crazy doubts but
sides are two of them no there's one ok
well it's under the hood nice because
there's the same flick your bean oh when
okay that makes more sense
I was thinking like two little egg
things on a table my gosh you know word
I think you just revealed that you've
never found the clitoris with the bean
yeah okay I mean look I've never been
good a jogger you got a bunch on their
minds
you gotta find the hood it's the one
that's looking like legolas that you
like was good you you know this is why I
just listened to you the shape of the
clitoris resembles a beam with a
wishbone I guess the man is like oh hell
thing that's just thinking like yeah
yeah
that's thinking of the whole stuff okay
yeah see I knew it I knew it was one of
those iceberg situations only saying no
yeah I gotta know true or false
ovaries contained one to two million
eggs at birth so the ovaries are what I
was thinking about yeah this is true
yeah all right or born with all the eggs
they will ever have at birth but it's
two million yeah the number I think so
one or two million eggs at birth yeah I
think I think so too because you you
have like a finite amount of eggs and
you lose them so I'm gonna go with true
too and then like every time you know
it's the only one that gets picked I
guess for the first so yeah there's a
bunch of them out one or two men sound a
lot I definitely think it's more
complicated than that but I think we're
on the right yeah I mean giving birth
for dummies yeah yeah yeah so students
these five days in a year right the
average person say like you you can bear
children from like 13 to 40 right so how
many days in that
and then you'd have to think about yeah
but it doesn't mean you starting to
million get links yeah it's a lot of
eggs I think it's true he's going with
trillions I'd say I'd say there's like
10,000 I know like yeah he's never true
it's going true alright Josh the truth
we are very fertile species humans how
many eggs through ovulation are released
during someone's lifetime oh here we go
30 to 50 100 150 300 to 400 a thousand
through 2,000 when we go for Pony to 400
quarter three or four I feel like I
think I like it even higher you want to
go a thousand I think it's a thousand
man josh is really like these people are
fertile thousand thousand it is if we're
just going if we're gonna stick to our
guns and think that we're right then we
have to go with a thousand two too fast
okay let's do it all right yeah stick
riding would ourselves mmm
I believe in the fertility of the human
all right man we've been here at 300
though for the records I said doing over
see ya Oh close yeah all right we would
have been wrong either way we did yeah
wasn't even on our minds see you're
right you're right on that one all right
true or false a woman set the Guinness
World Record for childbirth after her
69th kid nice I'm gonna say that's true
cuz that's so crazy that it's so crazy
it has to be turns out to be true I'm
calling it false
yeah I just like physically I feel like
things would break down like then it
would break down yelling after 16 after
like ten things just start breaking down
but 69 that's a lot I mean I'm not here
to tell women what to do yeah but look
if you want station nine more power to
you I just thought that's a lot to me
yeah I mean yeah I'm gonna go false on
that - I think 69 is just too much oh
that's just nuts yeah I want to be
just sayin yeah you ain't even did
nothing sorry
you say I don't want to be today I
remember remember 69 people didn't know
69 people out waiting getting there one
power to ago the period starts when
which hormone is dropped testosterone
progesterone estrogen or serotonin maybe
her gesture owns isn't as smart when a
drop is robbed dropped is like I'm
probably guessing like level dropped in
its level that's well it would be my
guess I think an estrogen I think is
that straight as well yeah all right
we're rockin with estrogen say
progesterone I don't know what that is I
know what estrogen progesterone
progesterone Oh progesterone yeah like a
pasta sauce yeah all right we didn't do
too bad if I 54% you know that's okay so
that definitely is an F that is yeah we
above we above like happy yeah yeah but
this Annette I believe 69 is a passing
grade
I believe that's acceptable in my book
no way that's oma got a cool number also
the wishbone that's an exciting
revelation new new learning yeah
something here you learn more than I did
in school that's one thing so yeah no
still working on the clitoris is that
yeah yeah I gotta we gotta talk about
that I'm gonna put up a diagram on the
internet so you can like locate that
that was better cuz I was about to just
call my mom lay hey yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'll call my mom
[Music]